[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos puede que no os hable mucho de
este país pero lo cierto es que en donde
se importa mucho más de lo que te
imaginas
[Música]
más de 250 millones de personas la mitad
menores de 30 años convierte en
indonesia en el país musulmán con más
habitantes del planeta
pero no sólo eso indonesia amigos es
también uno de los países más
complicados veréis me explico indonesia
es un enorme archipiélago compuesto por
más de 17.000 islas que se extiende
atentos de punta a punta por más de 5
mil kilómetros aproximadamente la
distancia que separa a londres de
afganistán
con este dato ya nos podemos imaginar la
enorme variedad de etnias culturas e
idiomas que nos podemos encontrar en
este país y también las enormes
diferencias sociales por ejemplo
mientras los ciudadanos de yakarta son
casi adictos a twitter una quinta parte
de la población ni siquiera tiene acceso
a la electricidad
[Música]
en la universidad de indonesia no es
sólo geográfica y cultural diferentes
grupos están viviendo básicamente en
diferentes puntos de la historia humana
todos al mismo tiempo viajar desde
yakarta a las islas molucas es como
retroceder en el tiempo elisabeth pisan
y ya os podéis imaginar lo rematadamente
difícil que puede resultar gestionar un
país así un país en el que por cierto
pasó una buena parte de su infancia
barack obama si tal cual como lo
escucháis la madre de obama se casó en
1965 con un ciudadano indonesio y dos
años más tarde se formó a vivir a
yakarta y siento un gran afecto por la
gente de aquí mi hermana es medio
indonesia y mi madre trabajó aquí mucho
tiempo
barack obama pero vale puede que algunos
de vosotros estéis pensando pero enrique
por qué diantres debería importarme
indonesia qué tiene de especial este
país
[Música]
pues veréis amigos a pesar de todas las
dificultades la economía indonesia ha
crecido bastante en las últimas décadas
y aunque pueda sorprendernos
indonesia se convertirá en unos años en
la mayor potencia musulmana del planeta
y eso es algo que tiene muchas
implicaciones sociales políticas y
también económicas
notas el cambio hasta en la forma de
vestir la edad media está en torno a los
29 30 años esas personas jóvenes que han
salido al mercado que están mejor
formadas constituyen una clase media
urbana con un enorme dinamismo y ese
dinamismo es lo que va a cambiar este
país el turismo está creciendo gracias a
su demanda los centros comerciales viven
del consumo local se venden más de un
millón de vehículos al año
carlos gastón representante del bbva en
indonesia bien creo que ya te puedes
imaginar porque indonesia debería
importarnos más de lo que parece pero
antes de echar un vistazo a lo que está
ocurriendo veamos un poquito de historia
[Música]
la independencia
la historia de indonesia de indonesia
como país ha tenido dos protagonistas
principales su carne y su heart o veréis
indonesia es un país bastante nuevo no
fue hasta 1949 cuando consiguió su
independencia de los países bajos
[Música]
tal cual como lo escucháis indonesia no
fue una colonia británica ni francesa
sino una colonia holandesa y no penséis
que conseguir la independencia fue coser
y cantar para nada me explico sukarno
fue un importante líder de la
resistencia contra el dominio colonial
en 1927 por ejemplo fundó el partido
nacionalista indonesio con este lema una
nación indonesia un pueblo el indonesio
un idioma el bahasa indonesio
[Música]
claro que como os podéis imaginar todas
estas ideas no le hacen ninguna gracia a
las autoridades holandesas así que
súccar no fue el perseguido detenido y
finalmente recluido en una especie de
exilio en sumatra
una reclusión forzosa de la que fue
liberado en la segunda guerra mundial
por las tropas japonesas cuando ocuparon
indonesia los japoneses se aliaron de
alguna forma con los nacionalistas
indonesios para poder controlar más
fácilmente el país
pues bien el caso es que dos días
después de la rendición de japón en
agosto de 1945 sukarno declaró la
independencia de indonesia una
declaración de independencia que no fue
reconocida por las autoridades
holandesas
lejos de ello trataron de reestablecer
su poder mediante la fuerza
comenzó así la llamada revolución
nacional que duró cuatro años y que
amigos fue muy pero que muy sangrienta
holanda investigará su oscuro pasado
colonial en indonesia para que os hagáis
una idea se calcula que en apenas cuatro
años más de 100.000 indonesios y 5000
soldados holandeses perdieron la vida y
así fue como finalmente en 1949 tras
mucho demasiado sufrimiento las
autoridades holandesas aceptaron y
reconocieron la independencia de este
país
[Música]
dos dictaduras
y amigos que indonesia logrará la
independencia no quiere decir que la
libertad llegará al país para nada
durante los siguientes 18 años sukarno
dirigió indonesia de una forma cada vez
más autoritaria bajo un modelo que se
conoció como la democracia dirigida y
amigos palabra cada vez que se le pone
un adjetivo al término democracia suele
ser todo menos democracia el caso es que
durante este tiempo se produjeron todo
tipo de problemas el país era muy pero
que muy pobre la economía no funcionaba
y se produjeron todo tipo de rebeliones
y conflictos étnicos de
autodeterminación un conflicto con
malasia y muy especialmente con el
partido comunista indonesio el primer
partido comunista de asia por cierto que
con el apoyo de china y la unión
soviética era cada vez más importante en
el país veréis sukarno aunque no era
considerado como un líder comunista si
fue un líder de corte socialista al que
no le importo acercarse a la china de
mao y que incluso recibió apoyo de la
unión soviética algo que no evitó que el
partido comunista
yo quisiera hacerse con el poder
pues bien en 1965 se produjo un
importante choque mandos del ejército
vinculados al partido comunista
prepararon un golpe de estado que no
funcionó
este suceso desencadenó una tremenda
represión contra el partido comunista
que le costó la vida a cientos de miles
de personas y que fue aprovechado por el
jefe del ejército
suharto para hacerse con el poder con el
apoyo de eeuu
durante las siguientes tres décadas
suharto dirigió el país con mano de
hierro con el apoyo de washington puso
en marcha algunas medidas de apertura
económica que tuvieron bastante éxito
hicieron que el crecimiento se
dispararan
sin embargo la violencia del estado la
represión política y la corrupción
estaban tremendamente generalizadas y
cuando a finales de los 90 se produjo la
crisis asiática la economía indonesia se
derrumbó la rubia perdió atentos el 80
por ciento de su valor contra el dólar y
la pobreza se multiplicó por cuatro
así que con este panorama el general
suharto se vio obligado a dejar el poder
tras casi 50 años de independencia y
dictadura la democracia en indonesia
tenía una oportunidad y finalmente tras
muchos conflictos porque en este país
los conflictos son constantes en 2004 se
celebraron las primeras elecciones
libres desde la caída de suharto
indonesia ha vivido un periodo de
cambios apertura política
descentralización y una política
económica más abierta al mundo aunque
aún con muchas restricciones
pues bien el caso es que en 2014 ganó
las elecciones el actual presidente yo
con cuidado popularmente conocido como
joey y calificado como el barack obama
indonesio
[Música]
joe y prometió liberalizar mucho más el
país impulsar el crecimiento por encima
del 7% cada año y sentar las bases para
que indonesia se convirtiese en toda una
potencia económica y política la mayor
potencia musulmana del mundo
[Música]
en ese momento amigos las expectativas
estaban por las nubes y en los medios
internacionales se hablaba de indonesia
como el país del futuro sin embargo
desde entonces algunas cosas han
cambiado atentos
[Música]
yo como y todo un presidente entre dos
mundos
la llenaba de yoko supuso toda una
revolución un gran soplo de aire fresco
djokovic fue el primer candidato ajeno a
las élites militares y políticas en
hacerse con el gobierno las redes
sociales como facebook twitter o esta
plataforma youtube jugaron un papel
clave
y lo cierto es que el nuevo presidente
empezó con buen pie en su plan por
lograr que indonesia se convierta en un
país mucho pero que mucho más
competitivo
desde su llegada al poder entre otras
medidas joey ha reducido y eliminado
muchos subsidios y ha destinado todo ese
dinero unos 40 mil millones de dólares a
tratar de solucionar uno de los grandes
problemas que el país tiene a día de hoy
la falta de infraestructuras
algo que hace que transportar mercancías
entre las islas del país sea fijaos más
claro que importar un contenedor desde
europa y no sólo eso el presidente
también ha puesto en marcha varios
paquetes para reducir la burocracia y la
regulación que es otro gran problema
una regulación y la burocracia en donde
ellas son tan pesadas que por ejemplo si
una empresa como inditex quisiera abrir
un nuevo zar en yakarta no podría
hacerlo directamente tiene que hacerlo a
través de franquiciados locales
[Música]
además muchos sectores están cerrados a
la inversión extranjera y el gobierno
tiene un peso enorme las grandes
constructoras las industrias
aeronáuticas los astilleros y muchas
empresas de tecnologías de la
información siguen siendo empresas
estatales
[Música]
además joey está impulsando también la
apertura de zonas económicas especiales
para el turismo y la industria y ha
puesto en marcha un modelo de seguro
médico que ha dado cobertura a más de la
mitad de la población suena bien verdad
pues amigos esperad un momento porque a
pesar de todo los cambios están siendo
más lentos de lo que el presidente había
prometido y más lentos de lo que el país
necesita por ello aunque la inversión
extranjera ha crecido las tasas de
crecimiento están siendo más bajas de lo
esperado pero desde luego esto no es el
mayor problema ni lo que probablemente
le cueste la reelección a este
presidente el gran problema amigos es
que en los últimos años se han producido
brotes claros de fundamentalismo
religioso
[Música]
una potencia islámica moderada
durante años se ha presentado a este
país a indonesia como una especie de
modelo un país mayoritariamente musulmán
que reconoce la libertad religiosa un
país que está cada vez más abierto al
mundo y donde las mujeres participan
activamente en la vida política el islam
tradicionalmente moderado de indonesia
es realmente una inspiración para el
mundo
mike pence vicepresidente de los eeuu de
hecho así es como el gobierno indonesio
se presenta al mundo indonesia es la
tercera democracia más grande del mundo
y también tenemos la mayor población
musulmana del mundo esto demuestra que
la democracia y el islam no son
incompatibles
joey todo sin embargo durante los
últimos años se ha producido un
incremento bastante importante del
radicalismo religioso es algo que están
denunciando organizaciones como amnistía
internacional o human rights watch y
motivos la verdad no faltas
por ejemplo el pasado año el consejo
indonesio de un lama la mayor autoridad
religiosa del país vino a defender que
los cristianos y otros no creyentes no
deberían tener cargos políticos en las
zonas de mayoría musulmana es decir en
la inmensa mayor parte del país
por otro lado el gobernador de yakarta y
estrecho aliado del presidente joey un
cristiano de ascendencia china conocido
como ad hok ha sido condenado por
blasfemia al insinuar que la política
debería dejar a un lado la religión
y además en los últimos años el discurso
de los partidos islamistas se ha
endurecido mucho sin ir más lejos en
2018 están proponiendo atentos cambiar
el código penal para perseguir de forma
más dura
las relaciones fuera del matrimonio y
también entre las parejas del mismo sexo
e ilegalizar incluso la convivencia de
parejas solteras rojo de momento
indonesia sigue siendo por lo general un
país relativamente moderado y la inmensa
mayor parte de la población apoya una
democracia abierta e incluso la libertad
religiosa pero todo apunta a que las
elecciones de 2019 los islamistas tienen
muchas opciones de llegar al poder e
insisto estamos hablando de una futura
potencia que puede darnos muchas
alegrías o muchos quebraderos de cabeza
veréis si las reformas continúan
indonesia será un mercado enorme por
ejemplo se estima que en 2030 el consumo
de la clase media indonesia será muy
superior incluso al de alemania
[Música]
y además si gana la moderación religiosa
su influencia en el mundo musulmán va a
ser cada vez mayor así que la verdad
creo que a todos nos conviene que las
cosas en indonesia marchen por buen
camino pero ahora turno para ti crees
que hay que apoyar a este país para
favorecer a los moderados déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]